>> Tucker: A PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAD A BIZARRE EXCHANGE OF WITH
JIM ACOSTA OF CNN TODAY.
ACOSTA SUGGESTED THE PRESIDENT
HAD A DUTY OF SOME KIND OF TO
TAKE ABOUT JUDGE KAVANAUGH FROM
A FEMALE REPORTER, JUST AS SOON
AS JIM ACOSTA GOT TO ASK THE
QUESTION.
>> IF YOU DON'T MIND AFTER I'M
FINISHED, IF ONE OF OUR FEMALE
COLLEAGUES COULD GO AFTER ME,
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
MR. PRESIDENT, TO FOLLOW UP ON
THESE ALLEGATIONS --
>> President Trump: WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN?
WHAT DOES HE MEAN BY THAT?
>> I WOULD BE HAPPY IF A FEMALE
REPORTER WOULD ASK A QUESTION
ABOUT THAT ISSUE.
IF YOU DON'T MIND --
>> President Trump: I WOULDN'T
MIND THAT AT ALL, IT WOULD MAKE
ANY DIFFERENCE TO ME.
>> Tucker: JIM ACOSTA, A BIG
FOR WOMEN.
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST OF MARK
STEYN JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO LET'S JUST BE LITERAL FOR A
MINUTE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN EXACTLY?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
IN PRESS CONFERENCES THOUGH IF
JIM ACOSTA IS IN THE ROOM, I'M
IN FAVOR OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN,
AND IT IS ACTUALLY FAR MORE
CONDESCENDING AND SEXIST THAN
ALL THE OLD, DEAD, WHITE
REPUBLICAN MEN ON THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ORRIN HATCH IN THEIR WORST
NIGHTMARES COULDN'T BE MORE
SEXIST AND CONS A CONDESCENDING
THAN THAT.
WOMEN REPORTER REPORTERS
GENERALLY ARE TOUGH, THEY DON'T
NEED GENTLEMAN JIM ACOSTA TO
HOLD THE DOOR FOR THEM TO LET
THEM THROUGH SO THEY CAN GET A
QUESTION IN.
ROSLYN RUSSELL, IN HIS GIRL
FRIDAY, ROSE RUSSELL PLAYED A
TOUGH NO-NONSENSE REPORTER AND
SHE WOULD HAVE PUNCHED HIS
LIGHTS OUT.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT MAKING ANY
SPECIFIC CLAIMS AGAINST ANYBODY
BUT, HAVE YOU NOTICED THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT MAKE THE LOUDEST
NOISE IS WHAT FEMINISTS THEY ARE
TEND TO HAVE A MORE SPOTTY
RECORD WITH WOMEN IN THEIR OWN
LIVES?
>> I THINK THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
TRUE.
PROJECTION IN THE WHOLE       HE
PROJECTION IN THE WHOLE       HO
PROJECTION IN THE WHOLE       HR
I THINK THERE IS AN ELEMENT OF
PROJECTION IN THE WHOLE       HT
MEDIA SAVAGERY.
THEY HAVE HAD A HARD YEAR AND
LOST THE SENATOR, AND WHETHER
IT'S CHARLIE ROSE OR MATT LAUER
OR HEIDI WEINSTEIN, AND MAYBE
ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT JELL-O
BRAND HAS BEEN PHOTOGRAPHED WIT
WITH.
>> Tucker: SHEET THROUGHOUT
THE COURSE OF THIS KAVANAUGH
STORY HAS SIMPLY NOT JUST
IGNORED PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE
BUT SHE'S BRAGGED ABOUT IT.
>> TO THOSE WHO I HEAR YOU SAY
OVER AND OVER, THIS ISN'T FAIR
TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH, HE'S
ENTITLED TO DUE PROCESS, WHAT
ABOUT PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE
UNTIL HE'S PROVEN GUILTY?
HE'S NOT ENTITLED TO THOSE
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT ACTUALLY
THINKING TO CONVICT HIM.
>> Tucker: SHE BASICALLY SAYS
IF YOU SUPPORT DUE PROCESS AND
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, YOU'RE
PART OF THE PROCESS, PROBLEM SO
SHUT UP.
AND >> IT'S ABSOLUTELY AWFUL.
LORD CHANCELLOR IN ENGLAND DID
THE THING THAT EVENTUALLY BECAME
THE U.N. DECLARATION OF HUMAN
RIGHTS, THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE ISN'T JUST A CRIMINAL
COURT VALUE, IT'S ACTUALLY A
CIVIL RIGHT.
IT'S WHAT VISCOUNT SANKEY CALLED
THE GOLDEN LAW.
AND, IT'S NOT A CRIMINAL COURT.
IT'S BEYOND THAT, IT'S A U.S.
EQUIVALENT OF THE LORD
CHANCELLOR.
AND WHEN THE STATE ACTUALLY SAYS
IT'S A PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE,
ONE OF AMERICANS OUT OF
300 MILLION GET TO BE U.S.
SENATORS, AND NOT SOMETHING THAT
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE MOST POWERFUL FIGURES IN THE
LAND LIKE CARSON MILLER KNOW
MIKE GILLIBRAND, ARE WILLING TO
TRASH -- YOU MENTIONED MARK
JUDGE, FOR THE NEXT 30 YEARS
WHEN PEOPLE GOOGLE HIS NAME WAS